добрий день мої маленькі любителі
зеленого та парку слуга народу та
сподіваюся ви дотримуєтеся маскового режиму
дотримуйтесь умов карантину заради вашої
ж власної безпеки, а поки ви
сидіть вдома ми пройдемо короткий курс
онлайн-курс кумедної математики ось
зеленського вчора Володимир Олександрович
зустрів найбільший наш український
літак
марія найбільший літак у світі
який привіз нам із китаю
12 мільйонів штук у медичних масок
це рекорд, який буде занесений до книги
рекордів гіннесу
скільки ж важить 1 медична маска ми
провели нескладний експеримент та з'ясували
що одна маска важить 2 грами 12
мільйонів штук по 2 грами це 24 тонни
масок китайського виробництва
як стало відомо у січні влади
зеленого вивезли із країни 240 6,3
тонни масок українського виробництва по
2 грами кожна це становить 123
мільйона 150 тисяч штук
без урахування контрабанди тільки під
документа в лютому вивезення масок збільшився
лютому було вивезено 394 тонни по 2
грама кожна це 197 мільйонів штук
знову за документами без урахування
контрабанди і того що ми маємо
24 тонни медичних масок китайської
виробництва
рекорд світовий рекорд яких нам
привезли вчора з китаю -240 6,3 тон
масах українського виробництва яких
влада зеленського вивезла у січні мінус
394 тонни медичних масок української
виробництва
вивезених з України у лютому мінус
контрабанда нам це поки що невідомо
становить мінус більш ніж 600 16,3
тонни медичних масок це триста
вісім мільйонів штук
він що домашні завдання вам необхідно
були вдома підрахувати скільки б
медичних масок якби зелений і
його команда не вивозила українські маски
а за кордон міг би отримати кожен лікар
якщо нам відомо що в Україні лікарів
185 тисяч людей я сподіваюся, що ви
вирішити це нескладне завдання та напишіть
свою відповідь у коментарях до цього відео
а ми продовжуватимемо й надалі
онлайн-курси кумедної математики
Зелінська